okay so Matt where are you from West
Virginia
what part was the Appalachian burger was
smooth yes Princeton Princeton says
that's you
it's the furthest western part of this
breakfast at a Virginia yeah
no part Alex beautiful you miss it
miss you God
catch the essence people that like I
miss it a lot
yeah is a part of the bro this it is and
look at what brought you out to
California I was in Arizona and couldn't
get ID couldn't get what ID very cook
United yeah somebody 27 years ago in
Arizona you got ahold of my birth
chicken up changing Arizona driver's
license but they don't have no record of
who they gave it to I don't see how
that's possible you don't just hand out
driver's license with no [ __ ] alright
so they wouldn't give me the ID but I've
had ID ever ever everywhere else now out
of that idea in Arizona Oklahoma Kansas
Florida New Mexico everywhere I've been
at West Virginia I had ID Virginia
Pennsylvania it's just Arizona who's
messing me over but I came out here and
got my ID with no problems I did
restaurant
and holder I'm 51 years old
what and I know you're down on Skid Row
how'd you end up down here that's the
only place to go when you're homeless
that's where all the shelters are at
yeah yeah you get that you fit here get
housing here yeah Medical yeah
so it's very watery though oh yeah I've
seen people hurt here really really
really bad
I seen a girl get her throat cut I think
another guy get beat with a chair when
they're metal chair like you see on the
WWF's yeah she look fake on her because
when you get hit with a chair you feel
right and did hit him four times was the
metal chair came to his head she's great
so the lot of trucks are going on down
here you hope you've all that now yeah I
don't drink I don't do drugs
none of it
from alcohol for three years you drank
and drank a lot so you stopped drinking
oh yeah three years I'm not a drop in
three years yeah
I mean you don't need to be down here
and homeless and being messed up on dope
and alcohol because anything could
happen to you yeah especially a white
guy here here
what would you see what we have to see
happening the next five years of you I'm
gonna get it I'm getting housing the
game I'm getting my heart I'm gonna get
me another apartment and I'm not going
to have friends over anymore
because you see what
what happened with that I got evicted
over them so I'm not having no more
friends over my house and you can't
trust me
my mom lives in West Virginia my dad
lives in Oklahoma and you walking back
there you want stay in California how
much fish stay in California yeah I like
a winner here yeah that's great you know
it's are you from California
his code name is code then and as a kid
wouldn't you would drink about when you
grew up
you wanna be the truck driver
no I've been in trucks but I never drove
here married yeah go kids
yeah yeah
oh yeah I'm not been in trouble since
2000 so what's we're totally get into
stealing cars where you're stealing cars
that's not in prison
oh yeah last time I was there was 14
months on a deuce and Oklahoma Arizona I
was there before that I was there for
four and a half years and I've locked up
in Virginia for four years and then
locked up in West Virginia I did a year
in Pennsylvania you're like yeah I think
we go you know you can disconnect the
alarm easy what foot don't you do is
raise your head there's two wires there
which ones you click these what cuts off
your lawn right yeah my brother taught
me that well thank you for talking to me
I appreciate the time all right
how many kinds of a song I'm still
remover I didn't know over 100 cars yeah
and what age did he start about 14 14
years old mr. crisp are you're not a
driver's license the 14 I knew had
revelation in my life no fact I can't
get the driver's license
why is that somebody in Arizona got a
hold of my birth certificate
yeah and I obtained an Arizona driver's
license but they don't have no record of
who they gave it to how's that even
possible
so I can't get it I couldn't even get an
ID do I have ID here in California I
have an ID
Arizona wouldn't even let me get an ID
Arizona's gets messed up so
unfortunately sighs well I waited to the
hospital because my mom works there I
was gonna get some money from from her
to go buy some weed right I leave the
hospital
dr. Rosa fitness course rolls right up
lets it run it runs in the hospital
leaves it running I said I jumped into
some [ __ ] took up now I took it in
North Carolina in any in it and it got
rid of it for how long about that five
thousand bucks you sold of course just
write about them again that's funny
and
is it exciting stealing a car the
adrenaline and although it's gotta be
it's gotta be exciting right
but I never card you yeah ever done
you're stealing cars that have nobody
else the carjacking at serious time
hey what's the most money ever made
sonic car starts out what's that
program for what the Lincoln brand me
and the people you're selling team know
that they're hot right yes
take them to a chop shop they know that
somebody discovered okay yeah are they
gonna do is chop them up anyway
interesting you never still wake up I've
never stolen a car Wow
well maybe I should know they gave that
serious down for stealing cars how many
how much how many years in jail or
prison have you done for stealing cars
eight years and what's it like in prison
for what state were you in prison
I've been in prison to four different
states over in West Virginia Virginia
Arizona and Oklahoma
and what was it like Virginia was really
messed up whether I was a
maximum-security prison he had the six
years but I'm doing time with my first
he got three or four life sentences
ain't got [ __ ] to lose rested me for a
car ride winning the truck I stole in
Virginia right yeah underneath the seat
was a 357 Magnum Ohno and they charged
me with me it was in the vehicle I stole
do I didn't know the damn thing was in
there
I got your weapon sure and aggravating
it to the aggravating my sentence and
signature math and security printing and
the max in that number
I did a three half on six
West Berlin Virginia was nothing nicely
they had a right when I was doing right
to kill guards to killed inmates they
burned down the kitchen they burned down
the commissary
really they just wrecked the whole yard
which prison that was a maximum security
prison set Southampton well that was it
rough place we don't know we're joking
there okay I see people get stabbed
beat up how do you steer clear all that
stuff oh you just don't lose the best
thing to do is you know not to do in
prison you don't mess with them you
don't mess it up if you can't pay for it
you don't gamble you don't mess with
homosexuals a lot of people be doing
that they messing with them homosexuals
and they get caught up in [ __ ] yeah you
know you don't do that there's no women
around who they would see these people
in prison that are dressed up like women
they think they did they are women hi
yeah they want you to dress them as a
man you know as female things you know
what I'm saying
yeah they don't want to be called men no
they want to be just want to be
considered females in there
I've seen it all I know and Virginia
I've seen everything happened at Penn
but then you know I mean you've been
down to skid row you've seen all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] down there oh yeah
Steve your little table set up still in
there little man I don't see at all
right there in the street they don't
care because walk right by I don't get
foot they got bigger fish to fry yes yes
I've never been this was by the but
Holies here though
well you don't look like trouble well I
don't will you're allowed to panting
yeah see all you're doing is a pen
you're just a homeless guy panhandling
yeah you're not you're not a threat like
maybe some of the way no I'm not after
trying to give money for dope in shoes
damn robbing people - [ __ ]
come on here I'm sir those are not here
it's not butter robbery oh yeah oh yeah
it's just sitting at my foots yeah all
right
no you walk away from your tent with
anything valuable inside that tent good
luck
I mean I think what they do is they get
people high if you give them some spice
or whatever they get high they pass out
and then they problem all right man well
thank you for talking me again very
interesting you got lots interesting
stories you can steal any car is this
here
no yeah good for you I don't do nothing
around me I'm low know what they're
right I don't do nothing around how do
not break the law I know but you're
smoking spice that's illegal
oh it's legal yeah I don't think it's
good for you though well I don't think
it's I don't know just be careful that
[ __ ] okay each other
yeah but what do you do when you get out
you gotta pass the time somehow all
right it's good to stay busy yeah yeah
keep away from certain things yeah
they're made from stay away from this
neighborhood stay busy
push the boulder uphill
alright man thanks talking